the Joe Rogan experience that's what
makes fighting so great because you
never know what's gonna what's gonna
happen in in real fight you know true
true I mean even in box until you know
you see some some crazy [ __ ] like
Anthony Joshua just yeah
but you know you but I think in MMA it's
it's it's even more just because there's
so many different options and I have it
apart from a good source that Anthony
Joshua got dropped and sparring
the week of the fight Wow and he got
hurt real bad the week of the fight and
that he was very tentative coming into
that fight and very vulnerable wouldn't
make sense you could kind of see it on a
little bit you know with first round
when you when you even walking out you
know you can kind of see his his look
and and it's a little glazing it's a
little uh out of it
you know I figured that it was just
coming over to America for the first
time and you know being in New York and
it's a lot of that's a lot of pressure
and a lot of you know especially when
you talk about Deontay Wilder like
knocking the dude into into like the
next century like the week before did
you see that video that I posted on
Instagram from that Duty does an
animation no no oh my god there's two
amazing ones pull up first of all pull
up the Deontay Wilder one because he has
the the [ __ ] glove from the Avengers
and he hits this dude great rod rod did
yeah yeah yeah yes credible yeah he's
crazy
that guy's animation his graphics are
amazing but he did one for Deonte and
then he did an even more hilarious one
for Andy Ruiz yeah oh my god I didn't
see that anyway I did see the one with
the arte you saw I did see it they're
yours okay so what up pull up the Ruiz
one then yes so you can see when he when
he drops Joshua watch this [ __ ] it's
hilarious bad the guy's so good give him
some volume - can we do that or was it
the the soundtrack - do you think we'll
get in trouble for that
yeah no volume alright no volume just
play the video watch this so see even
the way when you're looking at Joshua
after the Faculty of this
and then if his body his body is still
there but his spirit roller roller bag
go through the airport his spirit has
got Tweety birds floating around his
head while Anthony Josh was still on the
ground his spirit gets into a plane and
flies away so amazing how he did that
the next day the day after the flight
that was out people are getting crazy
what they can do
yeah it makes you jealous a little bit
like alright you know wish I even had
that kind of creative process yeah think
it through let alone like go through
with it you know I know he crazy
that guy's a master though his ability
to do is the Deontay Wilder one they um
yeah I mean that is crazy
and then when Deonte moves away with the
eyes glowing
[Applause]